I am a public policy wonk
i investigate data that points to
problems in the American economy
problems like rising household debt
declining wages and benefits shortfalls
in public revenue and I try to pinpoint
solutions to make our economy more
prosperous for more people I out about
tax policy and infrastructure
investments and I get really excited by
a gracefully designed regulatory regime
these are the kinds of topics that I was
talking about on a public television
live call-in show in August of 2016 I
was about halfway through the program
when a man called in identified as Gary
from North Carolina and he said I'm a
white male and I'm prejudiced he then
went on to detail his prejudice talking
about black men and gangs and drugs and
crime but then he said something that
I'll never forget he said but I want to
change and I want to know what I can do
to become a better American now remember
my career is about economic policy as
translated into dollars and cents not
personal thoughts and feelings but when
I opened my mouth to respond to this man
on live television I the most surprising
words came out I said thank you I
thanked him for admitting his prejudice
for wanting to change and for knowing
somehow that that would make him a
better American the exchange between
Gary and me went viral it's been viewed
over eight million times and inspired
waves of social media commentary and
news coverage and I think people were
surprised that a black woman
would show such compassion for
prejudiced white man and they were
surprised that a white man would admit
his bias on national television
not long after Gary in my viral moment
we met in person he said that he had
taken my advice he said that my words
had been like someone wiped the dust
from a window and let the light in
over the years Gary and I have become
friends and Gary would tell you that
I've taught him a lot about systemic
racism in America and public policy but
I've learned a lot from Gary - and the
biggest lesson for me has been that
Gary's prejudice has caused him to
suffer fear anxiety isolation and it's
made me rethink many of the economic
problems I've been focusing on my entire
career I wondered is it possible that
our society's racism has likewise been
backfiring on the very same people set
up to benefit from privilege driven by
this question I've spent the past few
years traveling the country researching
and writing a book my conclusion
racism leads to bad policymaking it's
making our economy worse and not just in
ways that disadvantaged people of color
it turns out it's not a zero-sum racism
is bad for white people to take for
example America's under investment in
our public goods the things that we all
need that we share in common our schools
and roads and bridges our infrastructure
gets a d-plus from the American Society
of Civil Engineers and we invest less
per capita than almost every other
advanced nation but it wasn't always
this way I traveled to Montgomery
Alabama and there
I saw how racism can destroy a public
good and the public will to support it
in the 1930s and 40s the United States
went on a nationwide building boom of
public amenities funded by tax dollars
which in Montgomery Alabama included the
Oak Park Pool which was the grandest one
for miles you know back then people
didn't have air conditioners and so they
spent their hot summer days in a steady
rotation of sunning and splashing and
then cooling off under a ring of nearby
trees it was the meeting place for the
town except the Oak Park Pool though it
was funded by all of Montgomery citizens
was for whites only when a federal court
finally deemed this unconstitutional the
reaction of the Town Council was Swift
effective January 1st 1959 they decided
they would drain the public pool rather
than let black families swim to this
destruction of public goods was
replicated across the country in towns
not just in the south towns close their
public parks pools and schools all in
response to desegregation orders all
throughout the 1960s in Montgomery they
shut down the entire parks department
for a decade they closed the recreation
centers they even sold off the animals
in the zoo today you can walk the
grounds of Oak Park as I did but very
few people do they never rebuilt the
pool racism has a cost for everyone I
remember having that same thought on
September 15th 2008 when I learned the
breaking news that Lehman Brothers was
collapsing Lehman was like the other
financial firms that would go under in
the coming
days done in by overexposure to a toxic
financial instrument based on something
that used to be simple and safe a
30-year fixed-rate home loan but the
mortgages at the center and the root of
the financial crisis had strange new
terms and they were developed and
aggressively marketed for years in black
and brown middle class communities like
the one that I visited when I met a
homeowner named Glen Glen had owned a
home on a leafy Street in the Mount
Pleasant neighborhood of Cleveland for
over a decade but when I met him he was
near foreclosure like nearly all of his
neighbor's he'd received a knock on the
door from a broker promising to
refinance his mortgage but what the
broker didn't tell him was that this was
a new kind of mortgage a mortgage with
an inflated interest rate and a balloon
payment and a prepayment penalty if he
tried to get out of it now the common
misperception then and still today is
that people like Glen were buying
properties they couldn't afford that
they themselves were risky borrowers I
saw how this stereotype made it harder
for policy makers to see the crisis from
what it was back when we still had time
to stop it but that's all it was a
stereotype the majority of subprime
mortgages went to people who had good
credit like Glen and African Americans
and Latinos were three times as likely
even if they had good credit than white
people to get sold these toxic loans the
problem wasn't the borrower the problem
was the loan after the crash
most of the nation's big lenders from
Wells Fargo to countrywide would go on
to be fined for racial discrimination
but that realization came too late these
loans super profitable for the lenders
but designed to fail
for the borrowers spread out past the
confines of black and brown
neighborhoods like Glen's and into the
whiter whiter mortgage market all of the
nation's big Wall Street firms bet on
these loans at its peak one out of every
five mortgages in the country was in
this mold and the crisis the crisis that
my colleagues and I saw coming would go
on to cost us all 19 trillion in lost
wealth pensions home equity savings 8
million jobs vanished a homeownership
rate that has never recovered my years
of advocating in vain for homeowners
like Glen left me convinced we would not
have had a financial crisis if it
weren't for racism in 2017 I traveled to
Mississippi where a group of auto
factory workers was trying to organize
into a union now the benefits they were
fighting for higher pay better health
care coverage a real pension they would
have helped everybody at the plant but
in person after person that I talked to
white black for the Union against the
Union race kept coming up a white man
named Joey put it this way he said white
workers think I ain't voting yes if the
blacks are voting yes if the blacks are
for it I'm against it a white man named
chip told me the idea is that if you
uplift black people you're down in white
people it's like the world's got this
crab in a barrel mentality now
the union vote failed wages at the plant
are still lower than there are unionized
peers and people they are still worried
about their health care you know it's
it's tempting perhaps to focus on the
prejudiced attitudes of the men and the
workers that I heard in Mississippi but
I'm more interested in holding
accountable the people who are selling
racist ideas for their profit than those
who are desperate enough to buy it my
travels also took me to places where I
saw however that it doesn't have to be
this way I went to Maine the whitest
state in the nation the oldest where
there are more deaths every year than
births and I went to this dyeing mill
town called Lewiston that is being
revitalized by new people mostly African
mostly Muslim immigrants and refugees
there I met a woman named Cecile whose
parents had been part of the last wave
of new people to come to Lewiston these
are french-canadian mill workers at the
turn of the century
Cecile was retired but she had found a
new purpose in life by organizing
Congolese refugees to join with the
white retirees at the Franko Heritage
Center these men and women from the
Congo were helping these retirees
remember the French that they hadn't
spoken since their childhoods and
together these two communities helped
each other feel at home you know for all
the political talk about the newcomers
being a drain on the town by partisans
think tank found that the local refugee
community there created 40 million
dollars in tax revenue and a hundred and
thirty million in income and I talked to
the town administrator who was boasting
about the fact that Lewiston was
building a new school when all the rest
of towns like theirs and Maine was
closing them you know it costs us so
much to remain divided this zero-sum
thinking that what's good for one group
has to come at the expense of another
it's what's gotten us into this mess I
believe it's time to reject that old
paradigm and realize that our faiths are
linked an injury to one is an injury to
all
you know we have a choice our nation was
founded on a belief in a hierarchy of
human value but we are about to be a
country with no racial majority so we
can keep pretending like we're not all
on the same team we can keep sabotaging
our success and hamstringing our own
players or we can let the proximity of
so much difference reveal our common
humanity and we can finally invest in
our greatest asset our people all of our
people thank you
[Applause]